hi everyone
thanks so much for coming out this
evening we are really excited to
celebrate the last episode of season one
of foundering which drops tomorrow
foundering is our new serialized podcast
from bloomberg technology
every season we will go deep into one
controversy within
silicon valley our first season is about
we work
my name is sean wen i'm the executive
producer of the show
and i'd like to introduce ellen hewitt
ellen is the host of the first season
she has been reporting on wework for
four years now and she's seen the
company
rise and then crash hey ellen how's it
going
hi okay and we also have two special
guests with us today
cody quinn worked out of weworks
headquarters in new york city from 2014
to 2016.
she was an assistant to two different
executives that we work
now she lives in grand rapids she works
as an
executive assistant at the furniture
company hi cody
hello nice to be here thanks for coming
on
all right and lastly we have carl pierre
carl burke our reworked from 2013 to
2016.
he led the community team in dc which
means he saw their buildings in the city
he's still in dc and now runs his own
design agency
hi carl thanks for joining us
um hey guys tonight it's going to be a
pretty short event
we'll listen for about 10 minutes to the
last episode
and then ellen cody carl and i will have
a short conversation
and you can ask us questions too please
tweet your questions to app
podcasts or put them here in the chat
but first we're going to play a clip
ellen do you mind setting it up for us
yeah so we'll be playing a short clip
um from the final episode episode seven
and the clip we're about to play starts
off
pretty close to present day weworks ipo
has collapsed adam newman is out
and he's got a really nice exit package
um at one point it was worth 1.7 billion
dollars
and his employees are pissed because
they're seeing their own shares
plummet in value and thousands of their
co-workers
are getting laid off
great thank you let's play the clip you
can watch us listen for about 10 minutes
so just when you thought he was out adam
newman came
roaring back in and he's locked in
another battle with masa
this time about getting his billion
dollars it's like alien vs predator
the sequel but wework's employees
were out of luck they just sat back and
watched the stock
plummet in value here's carl pierre who
used to run the community team for
wework in dc
the sad part was where a lot of people
at wework were holding on to
a lot of options thinking they were
going to become homeowners when the
company went public
who were getting ready to buy cars
getting ready to
possibly even retire start their own
company and all those gyms were dashed
in the course of a couple of weeks you
know bummer
carl says he even watched colleagues
turn down other offers
because they thought they might get rich
from wework i have like two guys i know
um i do know they got job offers from
other places and i talked to them about
it and they refused both offers and were
like no we're gonna stick with this
like it's gonna be worth so much money
man it's like don't you gonna be a
millionaire
i've heard stories of other employees
making similar miscalculations
one former employee told me they bought
a house thinking they'd be able to pay
it off by selling their shares
another said they took out a loan right
before the ipo
so they could buy their stock early and
save on taxes down the road
once the ipo was cancelled they were
stuck with a six-figure tax bill
these employees felt financially screwed
but their disappointment went beyond
that
they were hurt i asked dave fano who's a
former wework executive
he said that the promise of equity made
employees feel like owners
but they didn't have the same rights as
actual investors
equity continues to be used
as a mechanism to create a sense of
ownership and i kind of use ownership
and air quotes it's emotional it's not
practical they don't have
the information rights that investors do
they don't really know the profitability
they don't really know the cash burn of
the company
dave said employees were also blinded by
famous stories of some early startup
employees who got rich from their stock
because they're just thinking about you
know those successful stories that they
hear of those early employees getting a
ton of
you know some some big liquidity event
and
and life-changing amounts of money and
that's not to say those aren't
true but i think it's
important to state that those are the
minority
in terms of the total number of people
that have gotten equity relative to
those that
have had real paydays dave says he
understands that some employees feel
tricked
almost betrayed by their own employer
that's tough for people to navigate
they're probably remorseful they're
angry
they wish they would have more
information and this feeling of betrayal
was compounded by wework's inspiring
mission
which dave says the company used to get
employees bought in
i think it went a really long way you
know you'd often hear
things like it's a really great mission
it's a real it's a mission i can be a
part of
you know why are you here i really
believe in the mission
that mission really meant something to
wework's employees
here's cody quinn a former executive
assistant
they made people feel like they were
like
you're part of this huge thing that's
gonna change lives
and they were really good at sending
that message that
so people really believed it i mean
really believed it like dancing and fist
pumping during an
orientation like they really got people
to believe in what they were saying adam
was like just a big lie to
you know and like i feel i can't imagine
how those people are feeling
former employees were mad because they
felt lied to by wework's messaging
we over me better together authenticity
especially after they learned about the
conflicts of interest
the huge payout adam leaving the country
in retrospect adam's old wework slogans
felt
hollow here's cody again if i could
ask adam one question did you
really believe all that [ __ ] that
you told us did you ever really
believe it did you ever really believe
that you were changing the world
did you ever really believe that you
were elevating the world's consciousness
or was it really all for that parachute
you ended up with anyway
remember others had told me they thought
adam was manipulative
and savvy that he knew exactly what to
say to get people to agree with him
he was so charming that it was hard to
know whether he believed something or
not
it was hard for employees like cody to
trust that adam had been genuine
to her and to others his actions
undercut his words
here's andrew again wework was sort of a
dream
it was really like it was really
exciting to me and to have that
dream dashed was you know pretty
devastating
and and when adam you know after the
fact
you know takes his money and runs off to
israel it just
causes you to question the whole thing
like was it ever
real was this always the plan in the
first place
and it just sort of poisons everything
that felt
positive about that this message that we
were sold
i was it was it just a way to get some
money out of the world
like maybe it wasn't uh
i don't know to this day i suspect it's
probably somewhere in between
i think that you know he's both
an idealist and a realist and
you know really believed it at the
beginning and also
took some pretty selfish evasive action
when
he saw the writing on the wall
there was something about adam though a
lot of people told me about this
they'd say that he seemed to have so
much conviction and enthusiasm and
energy for what he was doing
they felt it just couldn't be a
sustained artifice
there's something about adam's charisma
and magnetism i'm sure you've heard it
from everyone you've talked to
like there's a reason why he was as
successful as he was and it's because he
just radiates this energy and this
passion and this excitement about
what he's doing he's a he's a zealot and
so it's hard
not to believe that that's genuine and
recently i had a conversation with a
former wework executive
who had some great insight into adam's
beliefs he asked for anonymity so we had
someone else read his words out loud
he felt that adam knew exactly how to
use belief
to his advantage as a leader so i
think he understood that
people wanted to believe in those things
i believe that he understood the
perceived
benefit of those things i think he very
well understood
how to deliver a message that people
could connect with
and believe in i think ultimately at the
end
his actions showed that he
didn't really believe in the things he
was saying adam believed these ideas in
principle but in practice sometimes
things played out differently
he very much believed that people should
do those things and that people should
believe
in a we over me and that people should
struggle together
then when it applied to him i'm not sure
he believed that so much he felt
he knew like what was right for people
but
but didn't ultimately think that those
things were right for him
at least not in the actions he took to
this executive
this is how you reconcile the gap
between adam's words
and his actions this is how adam could
seem genuine when he talked on stage
about the value of community and then
turn around and do things that looked
really selfish summer camp was a glaring
example
when you know the whole company has to
wake up at
6am or 5am and struggle to sign up you
know to
wait in lines to go to summer camp and
riding a bus
and he takes a seaplane and look you're
all like
you woke up at 4 30 or five to get on
this stupid bus
to a summer camp to sleep in a tent for
three or two nights or whatever
and you're just getting off the bus in
the adirondacks and you're
kind of like you're cracked out you got
like one eye open
and you see the seaplane just like
gloriously land in the lake
and you see these like people doting on
him and carrying his suitcases and
you're just like
what the [ __ ] this executive saw adam
get
special treatment again and again the
people needed to share hotel rooms to
save
money yet he's got like a big airbnb
mansion
we're all told to save money and be
frugal and fly coach to china
he takes a private plane and so there's
just this kind of like
well my time is more important than your
time
in general like his approach to life is
the rules don't apply to me
[Music]
we'll be right back
and we're back so we're really excited
to have carl and cody here
both of them talked on the podcast about
their crazy experiences where can't we
work
during a time when wework was still
growing super fast
let's start with you cody after the show
came out what kind of reaction did you
get from people who listened
and cody you're muted sorry about that
got it um
i mostly heard from uh
earlier employees that i worked closely
with
so it could be other admins or
people that i frequently had to
talk to and work on meetings with and
most of the feedback actually i would
say
i will say this i've not got gotten any
negative feedback from anybody
so uh mostly it's been like that's very
accurate that's exactly what it was like
that's what we experienced
because they were you know in the
trenches with me at the same time so
um and and not all of the people
that i got feedback from our former
employees some of them are still there
um i that's i'm very proud of that that
i was able to at least talk about it in
an honest way that even people that
are still there are people who um
acknowledge
um that it's that's exactly what carl
how about you
uh yeah so i had a few dms
uh linkedin messages from random people
in the past
overall it's been really positive uh i'm
i'm happy to say that my times at wework
were
at least client-facing with my employees
was always like fun and positive so
it was more so like people wistfully
remembering some funny slash horrifying
memories from the past
but uh overall it's been interesting to
go down memory lane with a few people
uh who contacted me recently there's
like oh yeah so i remember that moment
where you know the keg exploded and
you know et cetera et cetera so it's
been fun reliving some of these
some of these painful but memories
yeah if anyone's curious about the keg
story that's i believe the opener of
episode episode two is the great the
great beer disaster
um carl when you worked in dc we're
basically running
um weworks dc buildings um and a lot of
people these days ask me
whether wework is still in business you
know they've read all these headlines
about
problems that they've had and the answer
is yes um but i think given your
experience i'm wondering whether you
think
wework is a strong business and what do
you think is going to happen to it in
the future
sorry i missed the the first part of
that question uh the internet here is
i mean i'm in alaska right now for
anyone watching yeah you can repeat that
question one more time oh yeah um do you
think wework has a strong
business model and and what do you think
is going to happen to in the future
you know what it did have a strong
business model um commercial
real estate was draconic uh when we
worked first entered it still rather is
in a lot of different ways but
uh you know when you're a small business
or a small company you can't
foresee your growth so it's hard to
commit to a five ten year lease to
anything
so wework really tapped into a model
that commercial real estate had to pivot
to anyway
but now with kovid it's really difficult
to say
oh no carl come back live
oh no you cut out it's okay it's okay
[Laughter]
did you want to say anything more about
wework's future do you think
do you think it will still be around in
a couple years
um it all depends on wework and what it
does now if
fred but really dumb leases if they can
kind of uh
start hedging back the really poor
leases they've already written or get
out of some other leases i think they
they could
withstand the storm um but um it all
depends on what they do now in my
opinion
it's gonna be tough times for the next
two to five years but if they really
buckle down
and really focus on core business
they'll be okay
i have a question for carl actually so
you actually knew about these
awful leases that were being signed
i noticed a pattern in leases at least
because i remember when i first started
what it was costing
a certain cost per square footage
especially with construction and build
outs
and then it just got kind of wilder and
i was like really we're gonna i remember
being like scratching my head like
this
manipulate it in a way that made it seem
like it was
like this no this is good it's like it's
it's not really though
yeah i think i think i think we work
what at least
during my heydays at wework it was
really at that point where
growth mattered no matter what as long
as on paper we looked like we were
growing
that's all that mattered we could we
could have written
the worst membership agreement
commitments ever was like oh you get
half a year off and then your next
year's
you know two-thirds price like some of
the craziest stuff i've ever seen
in terms of lease agreements were kind
of flying all over the place but
it was in that weird time period of like
growth is
everything if we're growing that means
we're okay
and i think that's a mentality of
silicon valley that
it's like who cares about users or you
know how to make money or you know
actual revenue coming in to offset you
know and you see you've seen it with
a lot of the bigger companies on ipl
like snapchat and uber everyone's like
oh i think times are tough for these
companies because
at no point do they slap themselves in
the face and like are we growing too
fast what's responsible growth look like
um should we commit to this this market
is it a good time to enter this market
instead of this
you know we're first ones here that's
all that matters so i don't know it's
it's stuff
um both of you you know i we obviously
interviewed a lot of
um former employees of wework for the
show but both of you had i think pretty
colorful and hilarious experiences
of your time at wework and i'm wondering
if you maybe we'll start with cody do
you want to share a couple things like
when you think back on your time there
what what sticks out to you it's like an
unusual experience
so i would say this this wasn't unusual
to me
at the time but in hindsight
when i look at it and like that is so
abnormal
um i remember like having to do expenses
for someone and like they had spent
probably like 10 to 12 000
on our trip to san francisco and
never brought back a single receipt
and i was like um like i was i was
getting
because i was the you know i was in
charge of this so like like
hey like we need receipts you have to do
these expenses
and i i would ask this person it's just
like i don't know figure it out i don't
have them
this is twelve thousand dollars of
company expenses and you're just telling
me to figure it out
like you already go to go to procurement
you're like
i don't know what do you want me to do i
got nothing like
that was the weirdest like like it was
weird
at the time but like now that i work you
know
in a company that like has
um processes and functions that are
long-standing
when i look back i'm like that's really
bizarre that's not normal
at all um so that's one
and then like another another one was um
like when you every anytime i would ever
have a question
to bring sorry i got the dog here um
um every time i'd ask hr about like hey
like is this normal is
like or like could i talk to somebody
about something that makes
is making me feel kind of like
uncomfortable
or like can i have a conversation
with somebody about something that i
think
needs attention i i would basically
i'd be told like um
so no no we can't do that for you
we can't we can't talk to you about that
you should just talk to your manager
or like whoever it is and i'm like well
but
like you're supposed to be the oversight
on like problems with
between like you know managers and and
their reports
and you're telling me that i cannot come
to you
at all with anything ever
and they were like yeah pretty much yep
yep so just
i don't know figure it out that was just
bizarre
that like just this is strange that was
a strange
um i guess construct of of
how employees interacted within a
company that was
scaling that fast
yeah i think i think if there's one
theme i've heard that in companies and
and not just that we work to be fair but
companies that are growing very quickly
like the normal process is just
kind of you know it's they get left
behind right
um carl what about you anything
i'm sorry i told you she would get in
here
any particular memories that you like to
reminisce about the funniest or the
weirdest ones
i remember uh i remember before adam
came into town
uh i was getting ready to go on this big
tour with him and look at all these
buildings and meet up with brokers and i
was wearing a really nice three-piece
suit
and i was getting like really had my
hair done i was like really feeling
feeling it and then uh and i was at
wonder one of our locations at the one
bread factory location
and the keg broke and there was nobody
there who can fix it and like i don't
want angry members or except members so
i literally just
took off my jacket and started fixing it
in my nice suit
and i remember just the keg like i fixed
it but a lot of build-up of co2 was in
there so it just kind of spat at me and
got beer all over me
and i was just like uh so i had i went
to i went to a store real quick just to
change out my shirt
but i still smelled like beer i just you
can never
i feel like that's one thing that we
work that'll i'll never scrub off my
skin that's an old beer smell
um but the other crazy part of that
story was i remember going to all those
meetings later with
with uh with adam and some other team
and we're just meeting with all these
developers
and then we would have like the meeting
inside the car when the developers
weren't there where's that car
what do you think of this building blah
blah and you know i'm i was 26 or
27 at the time and it was just crazy
like
putting my input into like what would be
like a 10 million dollar deal
or like all these huge deals and i was
just like getting kind of uncomfortable
i was like uh you know because it was on
me to sell the building too it was like
all right we'll we'll get this building
but it's on you to make sure it's fully
leased up
so we kept this crazy tour we basically
said yes
to everything like it was like window
shopping with millions of dollars
and it was just as a as a very pro
as a person in their 20s it's wildly
uncomforting just to be like in that
position where it's like all right
we'll do it but it's on you to make sure
it doesn't fail so it's like cool man
and that being covered in beer that was
that was a fun day um but that was like
every other day that we worked though
some other crazy
wild challenge while being covered in
beer
i haven't i have one more if if that if
that's okay
i it i buried a lot of the stuff in my
head but um i once had to give tiffany
trump a
tour of a weedwork headquarters
in chelsea i was like wait what
yeah yeah just just walk around as a
customer what
as a she just knew
somebody like her i think her mom knew
somebody and she
she was finishing school and i was there
it was like
oh yeah well tiffany shot tell me i said
you know just just give her just give
her a tour really quick and i'm like
wait wait wait a minute wait who what
i'm doing what and i was like wearing
jeans and like
tennis shoes i'm like i'm okay all right
cool
she was honestly lovely she was very
nice
but that was really bizarre so um
yeah like carl like you get thrown into
like the weirdest stuff
that you're you're like oh my god really
okay all right okay
well just oh i guess i'll figure it out
then celebrity tours were super common
or celebrities dropping and we work was
actually very very common
uh and in dc we had a few senators and
random people like that come through but
there's always like a thing where you
try to find the security footage to
prove it it's like look this person's
actually here like there's 50 cent
at that guy's office right there um yeah
we have a question from periscope from d
wadi19911
do do you guys still have friends that
we work and would you go
back to wework as an employee ever
friends yes go back not anytime soon
uh yeah i have i have i think one last
friend there a lot i joined wework
super early i guess for most people and
i was a lot of my older friends were
like part of the og
crew but when adam left a lot of them
kind of departed as well
um now when i go back i mean if they
could really prove to me corporate
governance is a lot better and
they have a real battle plan to weather
the storm that's coming up and they
offered me
stupid cash uh no more stock options
cash only from now on
uh yeah that's the thing that we worked
too was you know
i was getting paid crazy low amounts for
what i was managing i was managing
a 35 million p l and i was getting paid
like
68 000 a year and you don't really
realize how little that is compared to
what you should be getting
when you're you know 25 you're just like
cool
you know startups beer fun people and
that's all goes through your head but
when you settle in and start doing the
work and crunching the numbers
it really is kind of terrifying how much
you're managing in terms of like
how big of a property it is but yeah
uh we have another question from twitter
from port
what do you guys think the future holds
for all those work offices that are
sitting empty right now
i honestly think wework is too big to
fail i mean
this my friends always think i'm crazy
but i mean think about it
if we work went under belly up right now
they are the biggest commercial
uh uh commercial leaser
in new york and london like the the
economy there's a tank like literally
tank if we were just all of a sudden ran
out of money
um they've spread themselves like crazy
over so many properties across the globe
and
have gobbled up so much real estate it's
it won't magically i mean it'll continue
to bleed for a while but i don't see it
magically just going away overnight um
and
landlords won't allow it to happen it's
almost like being bailed out like it's
for all the banks i got bailed out
during the
last time the economy crashed it's kind
of like that it's like these landlords
can't afford to have wework go under so
they'll figure something out
i agree with carl on that um
i think there has been enough money
invested at this point that
um and it's also been invested by
entities that like they they could
lose some for a little while it's you
know like it's not like
their portfolio is entirely in the red
these aren't like small investors or
small lenders um
i think that they will
back up their investments um
i am very interested to see how they
augment things going forward because of
covid
since you know you can't just pack
people into small
spaces anywhere um so
i'm i'm very interested to see that i
i'm still
like i still work in the industry-ish um
i work for a furniture company but we
also you know do spaces we design spaces
too
so you know um
so there's a lot of things up in the air
um
for the industry in general but i agree
with carl i don't i don't think people
are going to abandon on their investment
but it's
it's definitely going to have to get a
um big facelift and a
redirection um once we know more
i don't know maybe like at the start of
the new year um once we know more about
vaccines and
things like that um i think i think
it'll be
i think it'll be fine it just might not
look the same i mean i doubt it will
look the same
and they it seems like they've got a lot
of um
experienced people at the helm so i
think they'll be okay
john you want to do another question or
should i oh you're good
okay let's talk about summer camp so
this is what like
one of the things that i think about
with wework is that
um you know a lot of the things you can
say
about wework um you know that they
were kind of disorganized they were
super fast it's true of a lot of
companies
in silicon valley except i really think
some summer camp is kind of a unique
thing that we worked with like
there are other camp like companies do
off-sites and stuff but never something
quite as flashy and we're talking like
um
you know thousands of people going to um
these large outdoor three-day parties
with music acts and this kind of thing
so
just because i think it's a unique thing
about wework can can you guys talk maybe
we'll start with cody
can you just explain like what is summer
camp and and like how do you explain it
to people who
have never been uh so so i went to one
summer camp
um i know carl went to several uh so
i'll just talk about the one that i went
to
which is the one um i think we both
referenced in
in an episode or or two that um it was
the one where the weekend came i like
lost my mind i was so excited sorry
this is the dog sorry um
so you get on a bus literally at like
four or five in the morning
and you ride all the way up to the i
think adirondacks or with some you know
whatever some
that whatever that campsite was um
and i had like i had a great time i was
able
to invite my younger sister to
uh join me at the time
and um she was able to come and
and like great fun like we really did um
they that specifically
during the day they did try to like um
plan like team building events but
people were so hungover in the morning
that um
nobody wanted to partake so they just
ended up playing like dodgeball
and stuff like that um but you know it
was a good time
like i can't i can't say anything
negative about
my experience there um
but it was personally or the first day
excuse me
like employees and then it's like that's
when the members come and i think like
when the
when it's employees it i feel like that
was more fun when members
showed up not like not to speak poorly
of them but it's just like
it's such a um
it's such a um i don't know like you
you get to
um like relax with the people that you
grind with
like all day long and that you work so
hard with and
um yeah the experience was great i i
can't really say anything negative about
it
what did you guys think of the clip that
we played where an anonymous executive
talked about adam newman landing
on a seaplane in a lake in the middle of
summer camp
yeah i mean that's just kind of how he
rolled man i've that's the thing it's
like people make it sound like it's
amazing because i'm just so not i'm so
um numb
to that kind of behavior but i remember
when he was first visiting dc he blew
his nose into a handkerchief and handed
it to an assistant
like this is this this dude is just like
yeah it really is like a demagogue
status like when he rolls in
it's like everyone freaks out everyone's
like adam's coming it's like you know
it's uh it reminds me a lot of like uh
the devil wears prada you know that
everyone's just like freaking out making
sure everything's perfect when he comes
there he's just come in like a tornado
um and it's not as negative as you know
meryl streep was in that movie but it
was really that kind of gravitas where
it's like
you know everyone's like you know kind
of pooping a brick like you know making
sure everything is perfect because
he'll see something that he doesn't like
and that will like fall through so many
layers of stuff where it when it finally
lands on you it'll be like an avalanche
so he'll be like i don't like the way
this is or why are these offices empty
then he'll tell his assistant and that
person will tell your boss and you'll
just get the you know
the butt chewing of a lifetime like why
are these offices empty but you know
that's why it's just so like his his
slight dislike
or his slight movement one direction
avalanche is whatever
direction it goes everything has to be
as perfect as possible
but but i will say though um
i think it adam was somebody that was
very hard to gauge
like like what is perfect what is
what is he what is he in the mood for
today what does he want to see today
because like when we first moved into um
the new headquarters in chelsea
my boss put me in a like a small little
office and like he saw me in there and
like
flipped out but but he then like like
why is he mad at me like
it's not like i like took this office
myself i was told to
sit in here so i feel like it was very
hard to gauge sometimes with him
like what was he in the mood for what
did he want to see that day
and like like what
would be writing that day for
whatever vision he had like last night
in his dream like it was very hard
to say like like he was
not always consistent with things so it
was hard
to follow exactly what he wanted all the
time there were
sure there were certain things but like
sometimes it was just like
off the wall he would just be pissed
about things you're like okay okay
um so we have a question from xavier
from
youtube do you guys think that wework is
going to go ahead and try to take
advantage of the unfortunate looming
housing and eviction crisis in the u.s
by nabbing the properties for peanuts i
really hope not
but i doubt i mean what with what money
i mean
it's another thing too it's like yeah
you know a lot of there is a there's
still a lot of cap
prior you know contrary to what anyone
says there's still a lot of capital out
there in the world to be used and people
are trying to find places to park it
um i doubt wework will be getting huge
investments in the future but
it's not to have um anything left in the
coffers to spend willy-nilly
i mean they've had to they've told
multiple landlords we're not
we're not going to pay you you know
until we restructure this somehow you
know we can't pay our rent unless
so i i don't see a company like that
putting a single dime or penny
especially since their whole entire
their whole entire stick now is better
corporate governance and better
leadership
and gobbling up real estate even though
it's cheap right now would be a very
poor move i would say on their part
right now i would say it's a better time
to renegotiate renegotiate current
leases with landlords
try to position yourself where you'll
survive this because right now the world
should really be focusing on survival
not trying to get to
get the lead or get to take the
advantage um even though that's
they should do no but i mean for for a
company that's on the ropes
uh as embattled as wework is especially
with the failure the ipo their valuation
getting cut to shreds
and really being at this point at the
whim of soft bank i'm sure soft banks
and
investors and shareholders are like we
want to see
real moves that will produce real money
and we'll cover our costs and
make our investment worth it um true i
am coming from a place of like
oh yeah when we were there i i'm
i'm thinking about it um
which which is i mean it's not unfair
but it's just maybe not
currently accurate but you know i was i
was about to say like i don't know how
much
like um involvement does jared kushner
have
you know probably none because he's got
a new job now but
um you know
there are new people at the helm but
i hope that business practices
practices if you will have changed
enough where they wouldn't
they wouldn't prey on like vulnerable
markets
in that way but i don't know
that's how it started so i don't know
what sam weiss
from facebook is asking or on on
facebook not from facebook
is asking um people claim that adam
newman would light up a joint
and take tequila shots in meetings is
this true
uh yes i i never saw him light up a joke
no i mean and really people like to harp
on the drug culture that's more so like
really behind
closed doors they weren't like you know
these guys weren't like bumping rails in
front of like
you know what i mean like during like
meetings and stuff like that
um no there i mean you could definitely
smell weed sometimes for
at summer camp but you couldn't tell if
that was an employee
a member or your boss really because it
was just like one big party
but tequila shots yeah like crazy yeah
after every thing like that yeah
it's like hey we like for every occasion
you could possibly drink there was a
drink in your hand like
even after they fired a ton of people
tequila shot
like there was there's a huge culling of
staff and it's like even after then it's
like
john you want me to ask one or okay
um i feel like so it has been a few
years since
both of you worked there um and it was
as you mentioned
kind of an experience where you were
thrown into
situations that you may not have felt
prepared for i'm wondering
when you reflect on it what do you feel
like you learned from
working at wework or or what are lessons
that you take with you today
in your jobs that that you got from
there
maybe let's do we'll do cody work was uh
100
charlie okay
uh no no cody if you want to go um i i
for for me i'll make mine sure uh you
know wework was a trial by fire
um and i'll never complain about the
experience because
i don't think i would have ever have
gotten a more
pressed version of
business practices understanding
commercial real estate i mean
there's i mean i will always be grateful
uh who would give this kind of
opportunity to a 24
25 year old to run millions of dollars
of real estate p l
ensuring it's all full i mean i'm happy
that me and my staff rose to the
challenge and we were able to
do our jobs really well but man there
were days where i was like sitting in a
supply closet in a suit
like oh my god like like you know our we
were given our new sales goals and there
was some crazy number and i was like or
would you sign on new building
oh yeah carl that building's got like
1500 desks you can fill that up right
and i'm like yeah sure it was it was
we work was fake it till you make it and
pray to god that you can really be as
good as you say you are to kind of make
bridge that gap and luckily and else is
about we work we work recruited some of
the best people i've ever worked with my
entire life
i think that is the only thing i really
miss about the company is the staff
some of the most brilliant gifted
just you know incredible top talent um
it's a shame the burnout was so bad at
the company because the company would be
a force to be reckoned with
if if it kept people um i threw even
though even though it was a
really a puppy mill of millennials it
was some of the coolest people i've ever
worked with my entire life and and
they're
they're still facebook groups dedicated
to these people who used to work
together
uh they're like facebook alumni like
there's like we work alumni facebook
groups just you know
it's it's it's and that just shows the
power of how
incredible of talent in people we work
attracted
um so that is probably my greatest
takeaway sorry cody
no no i i would actually i would echo um
pretty much everything that you that you
said um
i met some of the like most amazing
talented hard-working people i've ever
met in my whole life
um and i also
will say that um
they in the earlier days i couldn't tell
you now but
in the earlier days they they gave very
ambitious
green but ambitious smart people
opportunities to prove
themselves and like you know we did like
we
we we really got things
well as they like to say get got [ __ ]
done
um and and
i i remember something that you said
carl you know about like
foot soldiers and generals and and like
that's
not only true just for community that
was true for
even people at headquarters that didn't
work for community
you know it's like you
it's like you you send them a g chat to
like
your pal and you're like i'm i'm gonna
cry can you meet me in the bathroom and
like you know and they're there for
you because they because they asked you
to meet them last week
like i some of the most amazing people
i've ever worked with i met through
wework
i will say that i don't think that
it was by accident um that
they hired people that were young and
strong-willed and smart and um
i don't know what the right word is but
you know like
like we would run into obstacles and we
would find our ways
around it every single time every single
day
multiple times a day we like we were
very resourceful and we leaned on each
other
so i don't want to give i don't want to
give like the old executives credit
for that because we built that ourselves
amongst each other they didn't build
that
uh they hired us but we built networks
amongst ourselves so i
don't want to give them credit for that
that was us we did that
we built that and i hope going forward
that
you know that internal culture um
lives on um because it's not an it's not
an easy company to work for
it's a lot of work and i hope things get
better but
all i can say for anybody that's still
working there is like lean on each other
because you need each other and
you were hired for a reason and
that's because you work your ass off so
you know
just ask each other for help because
everybody will step up and help you
uh we have another listener question
this is from jacob
on facebook he's asking if either of you
guys went to we
grow schools would you have vibed more
with wework uh we grow
is the elementary school started by
rebecca newman
um where that she got the plan for a
dream
and they sent kids to a farm ellen am i
right yeah for those who haven't
listened we
we talk about we grow and i think
episode five it's it's a
private elementary school that rebecca
newman started and yeah we did interview
someone who said that
adam had said in a meeting that he and
rebecca had woken up one morning and
she'd said
i had dreamed that we were kind of
school and he was like great
we'll build a school and so they built a
school and they sent their own children
there
um but it was it was quite um flexible
in its
approach to education i think would be a
nice way to put it no it wouldn't change
anything from
for me because that school was only open
for like what a few
no no i wouldn't even remember it so
no it wouldn't change anything for me
sorry that you like laugh at the
question but but
don't know anything about the school it
seemed kind of strange and
it wasn't open for long enough to really
have like a huge imprint so
anything that was really outside of the
core dna of wework tended to not get
enough it's almost like a
plant part of a plant that just didn't
get enough water um
they kind of gave you directives on what
to do but you're kind of left uh to the
side
and that is true of most the properties
that we work did outside of
their uh co-working so uh rise by we
i did not hear great things from the
guys there we live
i opened one in in crystal city in
virginia
and even that was like i thought it was
me the start of so many other we live
properties but uh it just kind of
stopped
and didn't give much support much
guidance and it just kind of wilted on
the branch and there were only two
properties i remember at one meeting he
was like we're gonna have like 60 of
these the next two years
and to this day they're only two i don't
i'm not even sure if the new york one
silly list
i believe they're technically still but
oh there's no
i don't i this is my conjecture but i
don't believe there's much of a future
for
we live unfortunately no i mean it was a
cool concept when it was pitched but
i don't think people understand how
complicated residential real estate is
yeah and also binding off more that you
can chew there's so many
laws and approvals you have to get i
mean there's a reason why residential
towers take
years of development and adam had such a
you know yolo attitude when it came to
like building stuff he was kind of like
whatever dude let's go do it
we'll just answer for it later but like
with residential stuff
it doesn't quite work like that you
can't just like oh we'll apply for like
a license for the beer taps later like
no residential is a bit different and so
i think it created a lot of um
speed bumps that were maybe not quite
anticipated or not
thought through as they should have been
even though they had a million
consultants that told them hey
don't do this and don't do that and wait
for this and wait for that they're like
no we're just gonna do it
um so when we were doing our reporting
for the series
a lot of people were looking at the
wework ipo flameout
not just as um a end of a chapter for
the company
but as an end of a chapter of an entire
era
of the 2010s for the tech industry i'm
curious about like how the two of you
whether you two agree that weworks ipo
ends
marks the end of an era and how you
think back on that era
the ipo that's so
um i don't know it's so distant i think
um
for earlier employees that have
that left before um that whole debacle
um
i think it leaves a bad taste in
everybody's mouth um
it's not like like i i didn't work long
enough to like have like this
huge amount of shares where i like
thought i was just
gonna be rich one day but i thought
maybe okay what could be it might not
end up being like a nest egg or
something you know it's
not so i'm not really like that but hurt
about like not making a ton of money off
of it but i i know there are a lot of
people
that that i spoke to
personally that um had really
they had very big expectations and they
really banked on it
and
i think that there are a lot of people
that are probably hurting quite a bit
right now
i'm happy that i got out when i did and
that i
just sort of said okay well maybe maybe
it's worth something maybe it's not but
you know i'm just gonna cut my losses
right now and move on
uh so i i'm not really maybe like the
best person to ask
but um i do think that there
there are a lot of people that um are
um probably struggling right now because
of that expectation
carl how about you i think as long as as
humans are capable of
experiencing excitement and as long as
humans have
stupid amounts of cash they don't know
what to do with uh there will always be
hype
around tech going to the new next thing
it feels like even in my lifetime i'm
like 32 i've loved to do like
three bubbles already like three phases
moons of tech
uh it's this isn't the end of ipos um
big ones either i think people will
scrutinize a bit more will change their
behaviors
how they evaluate what is a successful
tech company
um i think the bro culture of like big
money and big spending might tone down
there might be a more mature
age of of more interesting tech that
won't be as sexy won't always be like
you know
consumer based stuff or you know the
next snapchat but i you know i don't
think this bodes the end of necessarily
the end of ipos i think
it bodes the end of dumb ipos i hope um
of companies that people put stupid
amounts of money on betting
i hope this is the signal of better
corporate governance
uh for better leadership um i hope a lot
of ceos look at these as cautionary
tales
uh and also ultimately for me it's just
growth just like
grow responsibly it's not it's not bad
to have an appetite
to want to rule the world and take over
everything
but i mean the numbers have to make
sense and you can't just
the silicon valley thing that has to end
is let's do it first and figure out how
to make money after
if you don't have that back part i mean
it's just you'll never hit your
milestones
and but i say all this as investors
continue to still pour money into
companies like this so i don't know i i
you know if i had 500 million dollars
and was feeling itchy and just wanted to
not spend it on vegas and spend it on a
tech company yeah sure i'll probably
pick something crazy and wild and be
like oh these guys
you know but as long as you know as long
again as long as humans have stupid
amounts of money
and as long as people can get really
excited over stuff there'll always be
big money in tech you know
and they'll always be big losers in tech
too whether it's
yeah i agree with you i don't think it's
really gonna
change the fact that money's going to be
dumped into place
maybe it shouldn't but it's just going
to change the pitch that he's not
going to change i don't know
like maybe not be so bombastic about
numbers
um they will probably flaunt more like
inclusivity
in their workforce and probably try to
explain certain things about like
their impact on babies and environment
i don't think the money the money is
going to still be there it's just gonna
the language will just change a little
bit
okay thank you guys so much for joining
us today um our last episode of
foundering season one drops tomorrow
morning
um please subscribe and listen to the
show we loved making it
and uh we hope that you'll stay
subscribed for season two
um yeah and uh thanks to carl and cody
for joining us today
happy to be here